obviously i was here from day one for
carrington and just nothing really
wavered with that
and i'm at the point where i wanted
him and laurel to make it to the end and
now they are
and i think that says a lot about me and
my growth for being happy for people
that i care about
one of my favorite things about this
show is not necessarily the love
connections those are great but i love
the connections that the girls have and
i feel like you had a genuine
like you found your love island with
laurel you guys were so cute together
thank you i know i have said before i
did find my genuine connection and i was
like
that was with laurel because you know
coming into love island
uh i know there's like different like
twists and turns that happen
who would have thought that i would have
befriended like this girl
that came in with the guy that like i
really liked and kind of pursued
throughout the entire show
ah she's just an amazing genuine like
sweet person
and i love her to death like whenever i
was leaving i was like i know you love
this dress i was like take this dress
like i want you to have it like i'm so
excited to see her again after this and
it's just funny because our friendship
kind of was circumstantial with the show
but like she is
definitely a friend for life it was like
from the moment you guys had your
initial conversation after custom where
you were like
yeah we're good like we're friends i
never had a weird moment
yeah no bad beef or anything like bad
blood between us you know i like
carrington and those feelings are there
i was like very honest with her
throughout the whole process too i was
like i support you i think what you and
carrington have is something that's
real and i really hope it works out for
y'all too and i'm just
so happy that everything went down the
way it did
like for the last three couplings
because i was like they're holding her
hand with her and just like we're just
like squeezing each other so tight and
then when we heard
carrington say this girl brings out my
romantic side we both they were like
oh my god i was like it's you it's you
and like i know she's gonna do amazing
and i'm gonna be supporting her every
step of the way
speaking of bennett i felt like the
moment that you were done with him at
that men at work challenge when he
picked laurel which i thought was cool
because she was like down in the dumps
after what
yeah carrington did but then he was like
oh i did it to make you
jealous and i was like why would
literally
exactly to light a fire under my butt
and i
was sitting there and i was like it's
not how you do it with me but at the
same time i never really opened up
enough with him
to where he would know like that's not
how i do things but also another big
thing with me and bennett in the
realization that i was just kind of
not really feeling it with him in a
sense of pursuing things further for the
show
and like after was at the men and work
challenge before he picked laurel
i was just talking to the girls and i
was like oh my god like i kind of don't
want him to pick me
and that's a that's a big thing and like
i don't really want to go into a super
passionate case if i'm
having this realization and so whenever
we pick over i was like
uh i was kind of shocked and stunned but
i was like okay this
made it easier on me so you were
standing there when
carrington picked lincoln for that
challenge and
my god like you were standing there with
laurel you're the one that leans over to
her and is like see this is how he
like what was going through your head in
that moment i honestly wasn't really
surprised with
the fact that he picked lincoln even
laurel said to me
before the challenge she was like i know
he's gonna do this i know he's gonna
pick her like he has he was being weird
with her the entire day
you know she's like he normally like is
all over her in the morning and he
wasn't and i could see that he just
wouldn't really hang out with her
and that is very different from how they
like normally
like started off just standing there
being there for her i was like oh my god
and you know i knew he was gonna pick
her
and when he finally did i like kind of
felt her and i was like no you're fine
you're fine and then
you know after they did everything and
they got to the part where they had to
kiss i was like are you gonna watch it
and she's like no i was like okay but
whenever that happened to me
when carrington picked lauren for the
car wash or when
lauren picked carrington and i had to
watch it i was like no i
watch this i want to see how much he's
giving into it if it's more him or her
but you know i was going to be there for
laurel no matter what and i was like you
don't have to watch it
now that carrington picked laurel in the
recoupling do you feel like he's
all in on her or do you feel like
lincoln still being in the villa is
going to be an issue
how do you feel after carrington picked
laurel i
i have hope for them you know i think
it's gonna be like you know he's
probably
still gonna be looking over at lake and
being like oh hi and maybe still having
that interest because
clearly i was in it the whole time and
my interest never faded but
the fact that he chose laurel says
so much like i'm so proud of him like i
told him
the night before i believe that he
should follow his heart and do whatever
you know he feels is right for him and
not to listen to what anyone has to say
because like you came into this alone
and like you came in here for you so do
what makes you feel good
but i just feel like since he picked her
and everything he said
was amazing i feel like they're gonna go
beyond the villa for sure
good because i was disappointed in him
like i was like okay maybe him and
kirsten just like weren't meant to be
but now he's with laurel he seems really
invested and then he turned
out again and i was like karen i know
where to go doing i'm like what are you
doing get your head
in the game like you have an amazing
girl like i understand things just
didn't really hit off
the way that i wanted to with him and i
still had some hope
there because you know even though we
were just friends and i was like okay i
want him and laurel to work out like i
honestly do
and then people are probably watching
like how is this girl still like
holding out hope it's just because even
talking to him as a friend
and even just seeing him grow like from
how he was with me or just like from his
start
to seeing him open up and being more
romantic and just like you know
progressing and growing as a person i
was like that's so attractive to me
so that's what made me like even like
him even more but that doesn't mean that
i was gonna like
jump in and be like love me like i'm not
gonna do that uh i feel like what he has
with the world is very special
and even though i love laken too i just
felt like he made the right decision
i feel like your love for laurel
overpowers any feelings you have for
carrington
honestly yeah i mean it says a lot
because
you know i wanted the same guy i still
have feelings for him
a month like i was in there uh exactly a
month and that's not enough time for me
to like
i mean it is enough time to like get
over someone but not when you're
surrounded by them
like day and night a day is a week there
right like
yeah a day feels like forever to where i
could have
faked it or not faked it i could have
pushed through because i did have like
feelings for bennett
um not saying i didn't he was an amazing
guy and like
great person i was just kind of like
ready to go
and i felt like my time was there and i
felt like i was still like looking over
my shoulder and
you know still kind of liking carrington
but not not in the sense that i wanted
to pursue him
further and break that up because i'll
be like no there's no hope there either
but i don't know it just it feels like a
year one moment i want to ask you about
is when
the casa amor recoupling happened came
down the
effing stairs like he was by himself and
then
waved down laurel i was like what is
this boy
doing right now what went through your
mind that
was like that was probably
the hardest thing for me because i'm
very big on making great gestures and
you know
making big statements big and bold
statements and
you know i did meet a lot of great guys
across some more but this is love island
and you know even though carrington and
i left things off
as friends i just didn't really want to
bring someone
as a friend because i wanted him to see
wow she's still standing there if that
sparked anything then amazing
if it didn't then i got the clarity that
i needed um and i did
still was like mostly ahead of him
though but seeing that
was insane like i knew a hundred percent
okay 99.9
that he was going to be bringing someone
in and i prepared myself
for it and i still you know didn't waver
in my decision to
you know bring someone in like i wanted
to stand alone and stand strong and it
was just the fact
that like i'm right here i know he's
bringing someone in
and then the girls i see him walking
down alone i'm like oh my god i don't
see another pair of legs
like this is insane and all the girls
are like oh my god i'm like there's no
way that he feels the same way or that
like he had this realization
and so it went from like oh my god i'm
having all this hope now like this is
amazing
and then seeing him stop and turn around
i just crushed
it was zero to 100 and back down like to
a negative something it was
crazy i was like talking to people about
this and they were like well the
producers probably made him do that and
i'm like he could have said no
all right i don't want to do that i
thought the same thing
at the same time yes we can turn things
down but
i mean we're on the tv show and i
understand but also people had a great
point they're like
would you have still felt so like the
same way and like been
you know annoyed and hurt and pissed off
for sure if you had recoupled with
someone
and i think yes i would have because
i do i did have feelings with him for
like for him at the time
and so even if i was sitting with
someone having that
you know roller coaster emotions just
seeing him walking and be like oh my god
i'm coupled up with this guy and
carrington's coming back alone
i still would have felt the same way i
thought it was hard like
who does that and i remember saying that
over and over like who does that to a
person that's what i just kept saying
who does that but i don't think it was
carrington
it's a show there's dramatics but
i feel like he he does have a good heart
and so
uh it's gonna be very painful to watch
that back because
that was probably the hardest thing i've
ever done good old statement and to see
that
wow and then connor comes right in after
with the teddy bear it was just
one of the most brutal recouplings no
conor came in and i knew he was going to
come in alone because like
i saw how he felt for mackenzie and then
me knowing like being with mackenzie
knowing that she like picked jalen and
that she was going to pick jalen
and seeing him walk in i was like okay
like like i see his face
but then the people that were in front
of me like they blocked
his view of like his arm so i didn't see
he was holding
gus the teddy bear until he got closer
and then i was like
oh my gosh and the fact that he had to
like
give it back to her it was just
heartbreaking because connor's my guy
i love him with all my heart and he's my
cancer babe we have the same like
astrology sign so i was like you
understand me but
it was hard to see that too just to
update you on the outside world
they want to give it a shot and they are
currently
together they like i think he's flown to
arizona to be with him
mckenzie especially got a lot of hate
from the viewers so
you did i haven't seen my phone back yet
yeah cause it's just like you know
everyone's edited down into an hour a
night and the most extreme versions of
themselves so i know and so a lot of
people you know hated on her for being
controlling recoupling going back to
conor all those things yeah
what did you see from them do you think
they they have a real shot do you think
they're a good couple
i'm very happy that they are giving it a
shot because you know connor i saw
how he was with her and how much he
cared about her and like we had
conversations where
like both of us were battling like just
going home there were multiple times
where i've said like i think i want to
go home but i was like i don't want to
like i'm
not a quitter all this stuff i'm not
going to give up but like we both like
had rough times in there
you know i was also asking him like if
there was a possibility like
would you like go home like if you went
home would you go after mckenzie and
he was like yeah i was like oh my gosh
i'm like go for it like if
you really feel that you want to go
after someone wholeheartedly like i'm
i'm all for
big gray adjuster go for it yes from
what i saw though in the villa
is it did look like she was a little bit
controlling
but at the same time i feel like it was
definitely like a two-way thing
like maybe he wasn't giving her like
everything she needed and maybe she was
just expressing that and she has a
certain way of expressing things
i didn't really get too much into their
relationship because
you know i was over there like riding my
emotional roller coaster
um but i'm just really happy for them
that they're gonna give it a shot and i
think it'll work out
i feel like this show has got to be like
a crash course on how you behave in
relationships and like
what how like your love language and all
that kind of stuff like what
yeah what do you feel like you learned
about yourself and like in terms of like
your
needs and what you're looking for in the
outside world i learned that i am
stubborn as hell i'm very picky
i i kept asking for more guys i think i
had like 10 guys at one point like
you know i had carrington and then i got
asked out on two dates and then i had
five costs of more guys come in
all each of them kind of expressing some
interest and then i got
three guys coming i'm like i'm just
never satisfied like what's what's
wrong with me but i know what i want and
you know i'm not gonna let something
like this
kind of change who i am um but at the
same time i learn to open up more and
then i need to
open up i don't know i'm big on physical
touch i'm big on like attractive because
like
if you're out i always say this if
you're out at a bar and you see someone
that instant like oh my god who is that
like i need that because
you know you're with someone and you
want to be like all about them and
you know physical is big for me i feel
like that's not an issue
i'm just ready to get back out there
like i know well there's so many times
like
i would see you like connect with a guy
and be like great it's going good and
then the next episode i was like oh
she's moving on where's she going
i know people are probably like this
girl at the same time i was like i'm
glad she's not forcing something that
isn't
with anybody exactly because i feel like
if i were to force something with
someone it would be very obvious
because you know my body language isn't
the same towards someone that i
you know like versus i don't like and
you know it's all about trying
i just feel like in there i got so burnt
out i'm like i'm never gonna find it
it's just me like i don't know what's
happening but
i don't know it was emotional roller
coaster for sure
now that it's all said and done if you
could do anything differently about your
experience is there anything that you
would change
i feel like i did everything that i
wanted to do i don't know if i'd change
anything yes i would probably like open
up a little more and kind of dive deeper
but at the same time i don't know
because i know what i want and i go for
what i want and i fight for
for what i want and i feel like
you know watching back i might look at
things differently
but as of right now i feel like i did
everything as i wanted to